all right let's get into this week's
Patriot mail if you don't know what
hatred mail is it is when a professional
voice-over artist does dramatic
interpretive readings of hate mail that
I get here's a little more information
about hatred mail because it's God's
divine plan that every child be born but
an act of patriotic duty to snuff that
bastard if he sets a foot near your
stuff Patriot Man written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom all right there are
some not red flags but sort of calling
cards hatred mail bingo one of those is
spelling you're the contraction for you
are as why oh you are another is
anti-semitism another is homophobia and
on that list of hatred mail bingo is
also the word cuck and that is in no
short supply in this week's hatred mail
Pakman looks like a cup sounds like a
duck acts like a [ __ ] like Jared Kushner
Ivanka knows not to actually let that
weak CTEK root her kids come from a
different source red mixed with yellow
2018 will be the year of it tagline is
the implication that because Jerrod coos
nur or as we know him Jared Kushner the
president's son-in-law is the
implication that because he's Jewish his
seed is not as strong like there's some
kind of you just go back to like the
weird Nazi experiments on Jews and and
sort of eugenics type stuff I'm not even
sure I get the reference so that like
Ivanka wouldn't want that so she'd go to
another source to have her yeah
apparently so I don't even know if
that's the interpretation usually I can
somewhat follow the hatred mail yeah but
when I got the last line of this one I
just didn't understand at all a 20-18
will be the year of it the year of what
the year of the tag line of what tag I
have no idea I couldn't tell you but you
know what I think there is something
very very true here if it looks like a
[ __ ] and it sounds like a [ __ ] it's
probably a [ __ ] and I think that's the
most insightful analysis we've maybe
ever had in hatred
now you can turn hatred mail into
something positive because the coupon
code hey tree at 40 will save you 40%
off of your membership if you use that
code when signing up for a membership at
david pakman.com slash membership and
remember looks like a [ __ ]
sounds like a [ __ ] must be a cook it's
probably Alex Jones I mean it's probably
a [ __ ] yeah that's what I mean